this channel just reached eighty
thousand subscribers which is kind of an
amazing milestone remember the last time
I did a video like this it was ten
thousand which means that it was hounds
deep hang on battle is eighty thousand I
mean the Battle of the lease here within
web vercingetorix surrendered there are
about 80,000 people there on the Gallic
side it's not quite hounds deep is it
but celebrate this momentous occasion I
asked you guys on my twitter and on my
facebook to ask me questions and I will
give you answers so we are doing that
now I forgot to talk then how eighty
thousand subscriber Q&A go in a
challenge find a visual metaphor for all
eighty thousand people and the geek year
the better now I did a little bit of
research for this and the only thing I
could find was that there's a one in
eighty thousand roughly chance of a live
birth happening in uncle is it called
I've got it up on my screen basically it
means that a human can be born still in
the amniotic sac and a live birth
happens roughly one in eighty thousand
cases it looks pretty gross I'm not
going to put your picture up but if you
want to look at it that's that's a thing
so I'm saying that I guess is that there
eighty thousand of you and there's one
of me so I was the one that was born in
a sac Thomas as asked after finishing a
PhD what do you think will be the future
of your channel we continue blogging or
you start creating another content do
you think about it does it scare you in
any ways cheers in Portugal hello
Portugal and it does scare me honestly
because it's stepping out it's the
unknown really finishing the PhD is a
big scary process and what I want to do
is do video making full-time and I've
said this before that's probably going
to involve making videos for other
people and particularly science and
higher education stuff but what I want
to do my channel is to continue doing
vlog II type videos the kind of thing
that for example Casey will do
okay so nice that way he does a feature
I might tell a story and there are lots
of stories I want to tell but I also
want to start doing what I consider like
feature science content I have a huge
document of ideas what I want to do for
like 10 minute videos and I just need
the time to do it so the quick answer
yeah is some vlogs
definitely going to be a thing
particularly for another more ambitious
plan goes ahead and more science stuff
Daniel Brenner who was like me but in an
alternate form like abstract physics
singer his baritone as well hum has
asked worst PhD moments so far I think
the aftermath of meeting Susan Solomon
and not knowing who she was and
realizing that I've met one the most
famous atmospheric scientist in history
and didn't real and there's a vlog about
it I'll link it down there it's really
embarrassing Radian has asked do you
ever regret going into the sciences in
one of your older videos you've said
that you a good app and enjoy doing
history given things in humanities or
arts would have been more enjoyable and
beneficial to you and good luck
well thank you for the luck I need it I
would have been better at humanities I
have no doubt I always found essay
writing and history and English in
particular to be the easiest subjects I
found this very interesting but I don't
I don't regret going into the sciences
because I found more difficult I'm glad
I did been partly because they were more
interesting to me at the end of the day
but they were also want to challenge and
I think I was another factor I I don't
regret not going to it I can't think I
try not to Kate myself about in my spare
time and and weed up on stuff it's the
kind of thing that I would like to do in
the future but if I don't end up doing
it then I know I will have made the
right choice of you know degree on that
topic Shannon's asked what would you
have done if you hadn't studied physics
now it's very physics probably history
Austin's asked we thinking of making a
career in academia when you decided to
do a PhD yes
in short after I did a research project
in the summer of my third year I really
liked academia and in my fourth year I
did a master's project I was like yeah I
really like this and what I like with
the freedom and being able to pursue
your own ideas and I still really like
doing that but what has become clear
doing the PhD is that one I enjoy doing
this and doing media production more I
think I'm better at it than I am at
science but also the career structure
for early scientists is there's very
little job security it's very difficult
to get jobs
you know the way I like to think about
it is it's like being a knight errant
you know a questing night they have to
take on these odd jobs throughout the
kingdom like cure this dragon slavers
princess you get six months of
employment at a time kind of thing and I
I don't know that just doesn't appeal to
me so much I like the idea that with
this I'm the master of my fate the
captain of my soul kind of thing I'm in
charge of what I do on a day to day
basis which is scary because it means if
I don't have any good ideas I starve but
the freedom that it gives me again is
what draws me to it
Keith's asked which topics did you find
to be the most difficult when doing your
a levels and your BSC oh boy a levels I
remember coming out of the first further
maths class time when we could the
simplex algorithm and I was basically in
tears because I was like bloody hell I
can't do this but I remember for some
reason that really I really struggled
with that and I really struggled with I
think it was long division I just didn't
I couldn't identify the rules there was
there was something in in maths that I
really couldn't deal with then in my BSC
well my undergrad I'm gonna be all four
years I definitely remember struggling
with QFT my fourth year quantum field
theory because well the one thing I was
going through a lot of stuff at the time
and I wasn't exactly fighting fit but as
a topic is just so hard
and he's also asked have you ever
telling Simon had to do research yes I
failed all but one of my exams my first
year at Oxford
Ruxandra has asked what would you think
of the possible outcome of combining
physics and law I am really interested
doing that would like to hear opinion
ooh yeah that sounds cool I guess it
talks back to talking about science and
humanities that sounds really
interesting to me from a practical
perspective I mean obviously there's
stuff to do with you know nuclear
reactors nuclear weapons that you know
that's kind of big thing but I also know
of people who have gone from a physics
degree into a law degree and one of
these people I knew who is in my year at
Union is only more than 90,000 pounds a
year now four years later actually five
years later so if they left off three
years so you know it can be done and it
can be very profitable I think that you
know the minds of
lawyers and physicists have to work
quite similarly in a lot of cases it's
seen as very logic based Harry has asked
who has supported you the most
throughout your life and what gave you
the idea start making videos for YouTube
three sweet question actually obviously
my parents have been hugely supportive
you know not so much for the YouTube
stuff I suppose because I don't talk
under they watch on my video so I'm
going to a great saying that but they've
always been supportive of me
academically you know in particular
Colette what parents do and I didn't
retort to them about the YouTube stuff
and now you know my dad is in particular
is so supportive it's amazing at seven
one five
I mean obvious at the time well apart
from one they were very supportive and
you know encouraging which was what's a
big help and people go is fantastically
supportive and understanding of the fact
that I'm here rather than at the pub
with her because I've got a bunch of
videos you know makes all the difference
and my friends from home you know I'm
really I'm so privileged I'm why I'm
straight and I've got great friends I'm
like winning the lottery here and you
know through no action of my own because
yet my friends are fantastically
supportive and they always have been for
the most part you get the true friends
who rip that yeah they rip into you for
it
Katherine's arse doing a PhD is busy and
sometimes can be very frustrating how do
you manage to be energetic all the time
and get so many things done I am NOT
energetic all the time I I go through
phases I think of it a little bit like
Odin in the full comics where I will be
energetic for a long period of time and
get to be really productive and get
loads of stuff done and then I will just
sleep there are some days where I am
just I I always burn out I always push
it too far and it's something that some
people always criticize before because I
don't really care about my well being
and it's been my biggest weakness always
has been I push myself beyond what my
body is capable of doing and so I crash
for like two days at a time so in the
period where I am being productive I
know how do I stay being energetic I
just
excited I'm like a puppy of a person I
get really excited about stuff
particularly doing and making stuff it's
why for example today I have made for
videos you know and it's been like I've
been working on them since like 10 and
it's currently me 9 o'clock in the
evening and I haven't really stopped
doing anything else
I don't know I I love doing things that
you know I wear I make stuff and the
geeky and yeah basically I like doing
stuff I like doing that's a really dumb
answer Alistar is asked if you can have
dinner with four notable people dead or
alive would they be and why well they
probably have to be alive because it
might be very good company otherwise
admittedly at the moment I'm binge
watching the great wall channel on
YouTube which is amazing and you should
definitely check it out I kinda would
want to invite Field Marshal Hague Luigi
Cadorna conrad von hotzendorf and all
who else is another incompetent
commander GML Pasha and just sit them
down and be like what were you thinking
your mistakes are legendarily bad I just
want to know if I wasn't being
influenced by my viewing habits Gene
Kranz Neil Armstrong Buzz Aldrin and
Mike Collins because Apollo missions I
just want to I want to hit and talk Tim
Tim blade a capella science who
incidentally I am I'm honestly not
making this up
I'm so happy as just shot past me and
subscribers because a capella science is
all my all-time favorite channels and
it's finally getting the attention it
deserves
so you absolutely rocked him I'm dying
to work with you again when you have an
idea do let me know um if you had to
guess what would you say the world would
look like in 100 years and 500 years
from now um I feel like a hundred years
from now there's going to be tendencies
on scales to go to the extremes right I
feel like there's going to be a lot more
stuff that is coordinated globally
hopefully that means something acting on
climate hopefully it means sense to with
Fusion Energi as well but also I think
there's going to be increasing
localization not Nestor globalization at
the moment I just feel like
technologies are going to be invented
that
allow services to be concentrated in
small areas it's very vague answer but I
mean I'm not even going to try and
answer 500 years from now because other
than hopefully not the scorched
wasteland I I can't even see into next
week I am useless at predicting the
future
do you like my stickers by the way these
are from my my friend Claire who massive
shout out because she knows me all too
well how often hello internet and that
one I've got myself in Vienna I love
this laptop Adam McVie here's a I nearly
met up with in Belfast he's been
following four majors would you
recommend starting a physics vlog /
video channel and what advice would you
give to someone me who wants to start it
um I think it's always begin and if you
have something you want to make don't
bottle out up let it out you know if you
want to make videos make videos don't do
it if you just want to be famous
that's the fur that feels like it to
everybody in terms of wanting to start
it just don't worry about we audience is
going to think just make the stuff that
you want to make and use social media to
promote it send it to people and ask for
feedback you know send it to channels
that you admire and you know one in five
maybe will actually look at it and give
you some feedback but it's gonna be so
valuable and you know they're going to
appreciate the fact that you value their
opinion enough to ask for it and you
take that feedback and mold it into what
you want to do and go from there and
iterate and iterate and most importantly
accept the fact that it is not going to
happen overnight and you're going to be
terrible at making videos to begin with
because everybody is tomorrow's ask very
simply savory versus sweet sweet John's
asks how did you deal with the stress of
exams are more specifically the wait for
results um
stress of exams I never really
consciously sort of like struggled with
it it's just I get my head down there
work it's like it's my I feel most at my
element in a way you know because it's
just the work season and work is what I
do
waiting for results I find it's helpful
to just completely remove yourself and
when I was waiting for my final degree
results I was I went to Croatia as a
friend of mine and didn't think about it
once when I was that Chet asked what are
the right reasons to pursue a PhD and
what you intend to do after completion
I've been wanting to attain grow so I'm
thinking is I'm going to complete the
vibrations to the PhD is because you are
passionate about your subject don't do
it because you
can't avoid the real world do it because
you really want to do that particular
subject and you want to research it for
three or four years that's the I think
the only reason to do it what I tend to
do ask completion as I've said I'm
what's going to video production
full-time what made you choose physics
over any other science are Scott I think
I've said this before um basically it's
because when science split into physics
chemistry and biology all the cool stuff
was in physics I thought and I really
like the teachers for biology and
chemistry and I was good at it and I
enjoyed doing it but um I suppose any
really interested in physics Blackman's
our describe your reaction to the
election night using emoji you're going
to have to wait for the week in the life
log and my last week at term because Dan
and I do an election night special in
that I have Sasha's asked why don't you
share your girlfriend on the blogs but
you show her on your Facebook page and
good question I do and I show her on my
Instagram basically live doesn't want to
become a big thing in the blogs because
she's going to teach you next year she's
actually off to Cambridge they're PGCE
these congratulations in the comments
below and so she doesn't want to have a
big out there social media presence the
occasional thing here in that she
doesn't at least I don't think she's
ashamed to be seen with me online but
basically she doesn't want it to be like
the center of attention so other smaller
things like Instagram and Twitter
sometimes fine but youtube that's over
80,000 of you so it's quite a quite a
big thing
Annie writes asked what is your
definition of success is it a static
point that you will reach or have reach
or a dynamic but motivational point I
think success is defined by mother
latter it's a dynamic thing and it's
defined by the freedom to pursue
whatever you want to do in a way in a
lot of ways when I graduate and I
between patreon revenue adsense revenue
and being commissioned to do stuff and
presenting for the people I am
financially independent doing something
I love doing I consider that a huge
success and you know I can do good in
the world and do what I love
doing that is success vinícius is asked
do you plan on getting a postdoc
position absolutely not
and if the frown is asked who are your
favorite female scientists well let me
just look over there to where the poster
is I've said before that I have a
massive soft spot for great offer
because she's just so badass Marie Tharp
is very underappreciated that you know
confirmed the fact the plate tectonics
was a thing and continental drift so
hugely influential ada lovelace again
because just so awesome just yeah
amazing one that um people don't talk
about enough as well as one people don't
talk about this whole posters worth
enough
Linda be buck for discovering how the
tents smell work remember that was a
question I had as a kid didn't realize I
was a Nobel Prize being awarded that
roughly the time I was asking that
question for how the sense of smell
works and if I had to pick one more Emmy
Noether because it's like one of most
beautiful results in physics but if
every symmetry of the system there's a
conserved quantity there you have it
that energy and momentum conservation so
beautiful
she's also asked who your favorite
youtubers well I've already mentioned to
the Great War and a capella science go
and check them out for sure at the
moment I'm also watching a lot of King
grants I'm watching a lot of hat films
team double dragon a lot of live streams
that we all cast do I've also written
Lee had a big binge of finding new movie
and film analysis channels to subscribe
to so every frame a painting channel
Chris whale now you see it like so the
classic ones
there's also films and stuff digging
deeper Oh primitive technology that's
different and kurzgesagt
lessons from the screenplay case and I
start films and stuff how to make
everything yeah I've got a lot of
favorites at the moment okay I've been
trying to alternate between Facebook and
Twitter but now I've just got Twitter
ones left so I'm going to try and speed
these out as quickly as I can
Gabriella's up any recommendations
someone who didn't go to uni straight
off to second school wants to get a BSC
pursue what you are passionate about
ignore any job prospects of it and you
know if you get the degree that you're
passionate about and you do well in it
the work will come so if you want to go
and get a BSc you're passionate about it
do it and raise asked if you could
extend your PhD by one here would you do
it would you rather leave
the unknown I'd much rather gets the PhD
finished this year because I've been in
unit 4 years now and I am ready to move
on leap into the unknown with video
production the classic skeet how do you
cope with its fear of failure if you've
experienced it um I think I accept the
fact that the fear of failure is just
necessary if you are not afraid of
failing then you're not pushing yourself
and I just just knowing that I think
helps me deal with it
and also I have a huge amount of faith
um it sounds arrogant to say that I
didn't mean it's an arrogant I have a
huge amount of faith in myself like I
just believe that I will put myself in a
situation I will figure it out I'll
often say to myself when I'm in a
problem like you'll work this out you
always do I always do if there was a
book of Commandments for academia what
would some of the rules be us Joshua
thou shalt not passive-aggressively
tweet thou shalt not expect anything
from my supervisor and unless you give
them a lot of time thou shalt not expect
to have much of a social life if you
expect to do anything other than
academia in your spare time thou shalt
not covet papers in nature or science
and data is the LORD thy God
that's how no other gods before him it
shuts us what other area physics would
you consider specializing in or find
really interesting apart from
atmospheric physics um kind of cheating
to say fluid dynamics because that's why
I go into atmospheric physics that's
cool and associated with that plasma
physics like fusion physics I've always
found really interesting Joshua's after
what order would you rank the Star Wars
written trilogy in and why or the first
order would be five four six five and
four really close like five if
classically the one everyone says is the
best than it is because it intercuts the
stories much better but four has the
best climax probably in popular like
kind of film history six uh first
reading he walks hundreds are both
Kerman still alive and will he be
returned safety back to earth he will be
coming back to kerbin dan and I are
gonna be recording for sponging electric
soon because I've been out of action for
a while and so I'm rushing to catch up
with main channel stuff and Spungen
electric is going to go ahead we're
doing more of Kerbal we want to do more
on coop couch co-op stuff and game
grumps kind of style I'm also going to
do a lot more film stuff because the
summer blockbusters are coming and then
we're
excited to come some stuff for that so
yes Bob is going to be coming home quick
foul round from Katelyn Louise peanut
butter crunchy or smooth I actually
don't like peanut butter salted or sweet
popcorn sweet because I'm not a bloody
barbarian green or red apples red are
you now hungry that's my secret cap I'm
always hungry
Jamie's asked why did you start your
YouTube channel and I think of it as a
social mobility thing it was the fact
that rich kids who went to private
school were getting help into getting
into Oxford and they were getting asked
questions that I had no way of getting
answers to so I wanted to level the
playing field of it had you not gone to
uni what would you be doing right now
bear in mind how uni got you started in
filming um if I hadn't gone to uni I
guess I'd had just stayed in my hometown
like uni was was kind of inevitable to
me I was always gonna go if yeah cause
if not I probably did just stayed in
Keynsham
and would have started working and
probably been very unhappy Alex asks why
did you switch from being a liberal
Democrat to a Labour supporter tactical
voting both parties have a lot of
policies I agree with but Exeter is a
Labour stronghold and I wanted to make
sure it stayed that way because um yeah
tactical voting sure it's a film
recommendations and top three favorite
films oh I've got a whole video written
where I'm going to talk about my top 10
favourite films you can have to wait for
that Danny auntie's asks what do you
miss about school I miss going in
everyday I really really missed
sixth-form and hanging out a lunch with
the same people every day because
they're still my friends now I miss them
basically just keep potatoes asked why
are you so delicious Jackie potato has
asked are you happy with the choices you
made at sixth form to uni both
undergraduate and post yes um partly
because I think they were the right
decisions need to make but also because
I ascribe to this worldview that's our
more fatty you know you've got to love
the paths that you've taken because you
know to believing anything else isn't
going to change it so you may as well
love the path that you're on
Rebekah's asks what's the best thing
about being a youtuber the comment
section
I love the interactions with you guys
and smiling because I just released a
video with my weirdest comments are
being read out
Kailas Arts in vlogging your time as a
PhD student what would you say is your
biggest challenge or challenges um in
terms of vlogging it's editing editing
takes so much longer than people realize
and I've gotten very fast at it now
compared to a lot of other people I know
I edit very quickly got all the same one
the reasons I changed from doing like 30
or 40 minute episodes was because every
one of those would take several days now
if I want to edit like a 10 to 15 minute
vlog episode it takes basically an
evening but that is a lot of work in
terms of life whilst I've been vlogging
balancing everything going trying to get
PhD stuff done and finally cracking PV
inversion curve and singing and vloging
and relationship and trying to set up
stuff for the future and fitness and
losing weight so it's all a lot at once
Harvey's arse what was your least
favorite subject at school either PE or
maths
says the person who likes running whilst
doing maths PhD Tyler's asks what's it
like studying x2 some of us have any
application Susan quite useful
it is amazing I love this uni I'm
tempted just to make basically a free
advert for them because I love studying
here watch my ex locks if you want to
see layer as of what has been the
biggest challenge so far in your YouTube
career oh god that's a really good
question
trying to make content that I think is
worthwhile and that adds value to the
universe by me creating it but it's also
popular and also brings in an audience
because those two things are really
difficult for me to to manage to do I've
managed a couple of times got ideas how
to do at the future it's really hard
surface uh I used in a tweet the other
day top three favorite books I think
I've talked about this before but my
family in other animals brave new world
and zen and the art of motorcycle
maintenance what are some of it like for
you as a PhD student asks Evan any
vacation plans or business as usual I
have no plans to change I have got to
sing for graduation not doing anything
else other than getting my bloody thesis
finished which is coming along Evans
also asked what book are you reading
right now I just filmed a video which I
think will be coming out after this one
maybe about my current reading but I'm
reading a book about how to watch a
movie which is like a theoretical kind
of thing and a book about the Sun called
15 million degrees Marcus asam another
video
Thank You other runner I love seeing
when you make time for runs what's your
favorite exercise at the moment it's
sitting on the sofa I got out of
exercise in a big way recently because
ill and just been so tired my favorite
exercise at the moment though I really
liked doing middle distance runs like
doing 10k runs when I'm getting back in
when I get back into it and that's just
a sweet spot you hit and it spike
doesn't not like nothing else I've ever
experienced like when I did my fastest
ever 10k it was just like exhilarating I
loved it
other than that I do really like
weightlifting in particular I like doing
kettlebell stuff my favorite exercise of
all time is probably the Turkish getup
which is like a all body exercise but I
also I'm a big fan of squats they are
they are kind of great Fat Boy has asked
what is your favorite meme of all time
that is there's no way I can answer that
question if I have to give an answer it
will be the all-star Smash Mouth meme
but it's specifically it done as a Bach
chorale John asked at what point did it
stop dating strange caring around the
vlogging camera everywhere you go if at
all um you know doesn't refill strange
anymore
uh probably some point for the last six
months or so when I started doing weekly
vlogs or every other week we vlogs um
you just do it enough that you just lose
all shame imagine it's like being or
being a drama students like breezes ask
what kind of music do you listen to
other than classical choir music that's
false question I don't listen to really
anything of a classical choir music no
um what I love innocency recently and
then I'll just go through my most
recently played music this gives you an
idea from my Amazon music albums played
most recently Weezer deluxe edition
looks buy a watch as a higher than the
creation loves minstrels by Phillips
like it was a gorgeous baritone
Rachmaninoff's all night Vespers
Christmas music it's Jean Simon
Palestrina vol 1 by the sixteen
strawberries and cream my ninja sex
party the very best of other pets
Sam soft seventy number three another
version of Haydn's the creation parish
songs of farewell Bach's mass in B minor
wicked the UK album version messianic
quartet for the end of time
the very best the King's Singers oh and
an adopter who specials music and the
Deadpool soundtrack so basically all
classical music these are also asked of
what's the most annoying thing about the
British education system well the fact
that teachers are completely underfunded
and underappreciated they deserve so
much more money for the job they do and
Britain is gonna really go downhill
unless we sort out how we view our
teachers and academics more teachers
than university people and then lastly
Liam Williams has asked had choosing a
PhD impact your life socially as well as
mentally mentally if I'm being honest I
think it's been a great stabilizing
factor it has been enormous ly
frustrating and made me break down more
than once but it has been a constant
source of tasks and freedom and I've
really value that that gives me a little
mentally it grounds me socially um I'm
not a very social person so to be honest
I struggle to interact with with people
academically I don't know if somebody's
might find it much easier to talk to
people in a musical setting I am I am a
very introverted person and particularly
for catch me in the wrong light yeah I I
don't really get people a lot of the
time so socially it actually hasn't
really contributed to my life in either
a negative or a positive way and we are
done thank you so much for your
questions and this is probably been a
very long video if you made it this far
thank you so much for sticking it out
I've said before I am just so
unbelievably lucky and I am so grateful
to you guys the audience because like I
said in this video I love doing this and
I love making things and sharing it with
you and trying to make the world a
better place and I like to think that my
videos try and help people you know get
into education get interested in science
get interested in music and improve
themselves and make the most out of
their lives that's basically what I'm
trying to do and I am so grateful that I
get the opportunity to do that and in a
few months have the opportunity to do
this as my job that is nuts
um I am I'm constantly blown away by the
fact that people watch
I make so you have eighty thousand of
you signed up to get videos whenever I
make them yes
I'm so lucky I'm so so lucky I hope this
video went some way to try and convey
that and to pay you back through your in
some cases years of service subscribing
to me thank you so much if you enjoyed
this do liked it comment down there
congratulating this for going to
Cambridge comments also suggesting stuff
that myself and a capella science can do
because I am love to work with you again
Tim and also if you have any further
questions why not I feel generous today
put them down there and I will do my
best to answer them but no guarantees
I'm gonna be quick as anybody who's ever
email me will know thanks for watching
guys I really got to start say I'm so
lucky but I am